what's trending this morning with las
vegas now host mercedes martinez joining
us now live from the mix 94.1 studio
good morning mercedes we're so happy it
is friday
oh so am i good morning to you first up
let's talk about paris hilton this
morning she has finally tied the knot
the famous heiress got married last
night to entrepreneur carter room at her
late grandfather's bel air estate now
there are lots of celebrities in
attendance kim kardashian was there
paula abdul and last night's ceremony it
was actually the first of a three-day
celebration they're throwing a carnival
tonight on the santa monica pier and
then on saturday they're having a formal
black tie event
next up
pop-tarts i know you guys have been
talking about a lot of yummy foods this
morning but check this out the company
noticed a bunch of people were tweeting
about how they slather butter on their
pop tarts we're talking thousands of
tweets so now they're releasing pop tart
butters to go with different flavors sea
salt honey habanero cinnamon cardamom
and ginger dark chocolate strawberry and
finally
balsamic fig and caramelized onion
butter now these go on sale next tuesday
you can get all the butters for 25 bucks
plus you get three boxes of pop-tarts to
go with them john heather mercedes those
butters sound way too high-end for a
pop-tart that cost about 35 cents you
know what i mean not the pop-tart man i
love tarts i love pop tarts too and i
love butter but all right we'll have to
give it a shot
maybe they're trying to elevate them a
little bit you know yes with notes of
cardamom
a little butter garnish
something else that's also tasty and
very healthy kfc poor contraptions to
consume tell us about their new bucket
yeah i never thought we needed a bucket
holder but no one wants cold fried
chicken right so feast your eyes on the
finger licking
chicken mitten
bucket hugger i have to say that so
slightly
it's a chicken
chicken bucket cozy that keeps your kfc
chicken hot in the cold weather now
we're
we're not really having cold weather so
i guess it doesn't really apply to us
here in las vegas but if you want one
too bad you had to have purchased a
bucket meal
sometime between tuesday through
thursday and then enter your info online
but don't don't don't oh yeah guys i
have some possible good news if you
missed out don't worry they could bring
it back if it was a success i hope so
i'm trying to say that
chicken chicken mitten [ __ ]
[Laughter]
charleston sit with my friends by the
fire and crush some fried chicken and
put your hands
in a bucket in something
i'll bring the pop tarts of butter all
right
excellent mercedes thank you very much